nadie la esperaba pero ha sido electa
nueva presidente de la convención
constitucional en chile se llamaba
realizã quinteros es odontóloga
epidemióloga académica también tiene un
doctorado en salud pública es miembro de
la asamblea constituyente por un
distrito del sur del país la región del
maule pertenece a un movimiento de
izquierda los movimientos sociales
constituyentes ha obtenido 78 votos es
justo el número de votos para ser electo
presidente de la convención este martes
hubo 8 votaciones y ningún candidato
logró obtener ese número de votos para
ser electo ahora cuáles son los ejes y
desafíos de la nueva presidente ella
habló este miércoles de la importancia
del financiamiento de la consulta
indígena también se refiero al
plebiscito de salida del proceso
constituyente y dijo vamos a hacer todo
lo que podemos para dar continuidad a
este proceso